le mar je vous emmène où je suis né au
coeur de la france en berry
c'est l'été il fait chaud imaginez tout
autour de nous un océan de fleurs de
tournesol à perte de vue
si le beau temps persiste c'est de l'or
qui coulera bientôt dans nos ruches la
miellée sera belle j'en suis sûr une
semaine plus tard tout est mort au pied
des ruches des tapis de cadavres
d'abeilles ça craque sous les pieds sur
les fleurs tout proche quelques
butineuses rescapés qui ne butinent plus
elles sont tremblante comme prise de
convulsions
elle tente de résister de sa grille
mais aux feuilles avant de s'effondrer
au sol elles ne reviendront pas à la
ruche elle agonise sous le soleil
éblouissant silencieusement au milieu
des champs cette histoire vécue de
fleurs empoisonné qui tuent les abeilles
je n'ai pas pu me résigner à la terre
car cette histoire c'est aussi la vôtre
l'agrochimie à modifier radicalement la
manière de cultiver la terre depuis 1945
au motif de produire plus pour nourrir
les populations
elle s'est peu à peu
emparé du pouvoir à l'origine d'un
cercle vicieux sans issue fondée sur une
utilisation systématique de toxiques
toujours plus puissants parce que les
végétaux et leurs parasites ont
développé au fil du temps des résistance
croissante comme nos organismes humains
face aux antibiotiques l'agrochimie
s'avère une impasse
elle a détruit les équilibres naturels
elle a détruit les micro-organismes
naturelle des sols qui leur donne
leur fertilité elle a empoisonné l'eau
elle contamine l'air notre alimentation
une contamination généralisée invisible
insidieuse contre les effets mortifère
de ces poisons contre ceux qui les
autorise qui encouragent leurs usages à
travers le monde
je vais devenu lanceuse d' alerte pour
dénoncer ce qu'ils savent que nous
savons aussi que nous vivons les
maladies irréversibles que l'agrochimie
fabrique en série les menaces terribles
qu'elle représente aussi pour les
générations futures
les abeilles qui meurt dans mary chain
et partout ailleurs dans le monde sont
les témoins gênants d'un désastre
sanitaire planétaire que les apiculteurs
français ont osé dénoncer depuis vingt
ans les décideurs disposent de toutes
les connaissances scientifiques de
toutes les démonstrations de ses effets
délétères des pesticides sur notre santé
sur l'environnement sur ceux qui nous
suivront t-il encore continuer à faire
l'autruche
j'ai fondé l'association terre
d'abeilles en 2002 pour une cohabitation
harmonieuse des hommes et des abeilles
pour mettre face des astres pour dire à
quel point il est urgent d'agir
80% des insectes volants ont disparu en
europe au cours des trente dernières
années pour convaincre qu'une
agriculture fondée sur la biodiversité
est un impératif de survie pour
l'humanité il n'ya pas d'agriculture
sans pollinisation
il n'ya pas d'alimentation durable
diversifier sans pollinisateurs alors
quelle solution me direz vous la
solution tient en un mot l'agro écologie
accompagner les agriculteurs dans cette
conversion encourager les jeunes est une
priorité absolue
c'est l'une des conclusions des états
généraux de l'alimentation auquel je
participe et en 2017
sur le terrain les artisans à l'oeuvre
de cette conversion de cette transition
écologique
les paysans à l'oeuvre nous le disent
ils ont retrouvé le bonheur et la fierté
de travailler la terre je suis une ré
distante une combattante pour le respect
du vivant pour la défense de nos
libertés fondamentales
j'aime l'énergie des abeilles cette
synergie au sein de la colonie qui se
transmet comme une onde positive à celle
ou celui qui les observent isoler nos
abeilles ne peuvent pas survivre
c'est ensemble qu'elles ont cette
vitalité 7 ses capacités quasiment
surnaturel assurer leur avenir
l'humanité comme un essaim d'abeilles
interdépendantes d' à bout à l'autre de
la planète
l'interdépendance
c'est par exemple les pesticides qu'on
retrouve dans la graisse des ours blancs
sur la banquise cher à haïti la bei est
le symbole de la vie depuis la nuit des
temps présents dans toutes les
civilisations dans toutes les religions
la sauvegarde des abeilles est notre
affaire à tous
l'histoire nous montre qu'on a fait des
erreurs et qu'on y répète rêve
ou cauchemar à nous de choisir et de
réagir pour que le rêve reprennent le
pouvoir à nous de passer à l'action
passez à l'action change tout agir aide
à surmonter la détresse individuelle ou
collective
l'action contribuer à réaliser la vie à
lui donner du sens passer à l'action
c'est se reconnecter à la nature prendre
à la respecter décidé de faire sa part
il ya mille façons de prendre soin de la
nature en modifiant nos comportements
oubliée la bombe insecticide au premier
bourdonnement et voir revenir les
papillons les bourdons les abeilles
jardine écologique
pensez aux alternatives aux produits
chimiques
pensez par exemple aux coccinelles qui
aiment les pucerons des rosiers et puis
les mauvaises herbes comme on les
appelait avant découvrir qu'elles sont
utiles les voir d'un autre oeil
comprendre même qu'elles peuvent nous
soigner c'est un l'action s'est
réorienté nos choix de consommation pour
consommer moins et mieux
préférez toujours pour notre assiette
le produit local du propre de saison
avoir en tête que ce qu'on achète ou
qu'on évite participe au monde de demain
c
crypté l'information chercher à
l'approfondir pour tenter de savoir d'où
provient ce que j'achète et à qui ça
profite ce fameux pouvoir de nos achats
bien plus fort que celui des urnes
il est déterminant pour contrer la
puissance de l'agrobusiness de
l'agrochimie en particulier non pas pour
avoir plus mais pour être mieux
soyons unis est nombreux dans cette
démarche comme les seins dans la rue
passer à l'action c'est soutenir les
lanceurs d'alert de plus en plus
malmenés par des lois qui protègent les
intérêts économiques comme la loi du
secret industriel
les lanceurs d'alert aux contres et les
géants
il se met en danger pour défendre nos
intérêts ils sont surveillés de près la
proie de multiples méthodes répressives
qui vise à les faire taire les lanceurs
d'alert ont besoin de vous j'ai besoin
de vous est-ce qu'on
vous aussi pour encourager les
initiatives vertueuse qui se multiplient
à nos portes
beaucoup plus loin pour encourager ses
enfants du monde entier qui se lève pour
demander que des décisions soient prises
au plus haut niveau des états que de
nouvelles orientations vertueuse soit
donnée parce qu'ils ont accepté les
responsabilités n'est ce pas une
formidable leçon d'humilité attirer des
plus petits ces jeunes ensemble ils
créent la ruche de demain comme ces deux
jeunes filles à bali 12 et 16 ans qui
ont réussi à convaincre le gouverneur
d'interdire sur leur île magnifique le
plastique à usage unique
une initiative qui fait des émules
merci à tous ces pollinisateurs du
nouveau monde qui croient en leurs
forces pour réenchanter la vie agir
réagir pour rendre possible l'avenir
au coeur de cette ruche humaine que nous
formons pour que nos petits enfants
voient encore butiné des abeilles et
refleurir la biodiversité c'est ce
projet
réaliste auquel je vous invite à adhérer
accepteriez vous d'être vous aussi des
pollinisateurs du nouveau monde
je compte sur vous je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]